dans la lutte contre le coronavirus tout
est bon à prendre cette méthode semble
de plus en plus s'appliquer à la
stratégie de communication de l'exécutif
car pour sensibiliser les moins de 30
ans le gouvernement ciblent désormais
leurs influenceurs favori dernier en
date mcfly et carlito ces deux
humoristes sont à la tête d'une chaîne
youtube qui compte plus de 6 millions
d'abonnés
le duo s'était déjà illustré en avril
dernier en organisant une collecte en
ligne pour les soignants 400000 euros
avaient été récoltés
le chef de l'état a donc décidé de les
mettre à contribution pour sensibiliser
les jeunes aux gestes barrières je vous
lance un défi fait une vidéo pour
expliquer ses gestes l'importance de les
respecter
de ne pas nous rassemble et de ne
prendre aucun risque à avoir de grands
regroupements faire au maximum le
télétravail fait cette vidéo tout simple
et si vous avez 10 millions de vues je
prends un engagement
vous venez tourné à l'elysée les deux
youtuber ont accepté le défi du chef de
l'état la fameuse vidéo pour promouvoir
les gestes barrière a été diffusée ce
dimanche 21 février sur leur chaîne si
la vidéo atteint les 10 millions de vues
emmanuel macron devra donc se livrer à
un concours d'anecdotes avec les deux
youtuber ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'exécutif cible les influenceurs en
décembre dernier c'est gabriel attal le
porte parole du gouvernement qui
s'étaient livrés en direct au jeu de
questions réponses sur le coït 19 avec
l'influent suggest zoé à la tête d'une
communauté d'un million cinq cent mille
abonnés si l'enjeu fait avant tout
sanitaires il est aussi politique
d'ailleurs les deux youtuber mcfly et
carlito ne sont pas dupes il y a les
élections dans un an pour reprendre
leurs mots une opération qui pourrait
donc permettre à emmanuel macron
d'élargir son audience analyse cet
expert en communication politique chez
nos confrères du parisien
les politiques se relance souvent dans
le digital quand il entre en campagne
c'est le moment où ils redécouvrent les
réseaux sociaux puis après ils oublient
mais en pleine pandémie
et alors que l'on dénombre près de deux
millions et demi de morts dans le monde
la communication peut-elle se faire sur
le terrain de l'humour sur les réseaux
sociaux l'annoncent
vidéo de youtube heures mcfly et carlito
a essuyé de nombreuses critiques et
indignation mais pour ce conseiller en
communication tout est une question
d'équilibré
l'humour permettent à un message d'être
bien plus efficace mais génère en
contrepartie de nombreuses réactions
négatives de moqueries de personnes qui
pensent que cela n'est pas approprié
tout l'équilibré là est ce que cela vaut
le coup pour leurs vidéos mcfly et
carlito précise que tout l'argent généré
ira aux étudiants car leur situation est
très précaire d'après leurs propres mots
les deux youtuber qui n'ont pas vocation
à faire de la politique ont prévenu
leurs abonnés gardez votre esprit
critique